So take a look at this diagram.
>> Okay.
>> Can you tell me what this is?
>> Yeah, Amie, it's an ear.
>> Okay, it is and can you tell me what
happens when a sound wave comes and enters our ear?
>> Well, I'm guessing it's collected by this tube thing here right?
>> Exactly, and that tube thing is called the
ear canal. And then what do you think happens?
>> Then, it gets to this thing here.
>> That's right. And this thing is called the eardrum, and it's
a tight membrane that vibrates at the
same frequency as this incoming sound wave.
>> That's really cool Andy, but then, what
are these things that's connected to the eardrum?
>> These are three tiny bones. So. The
vibrations in the eardrum cause these bones to vibrate.
>> Alright, well then, what happens when
the vibrations get to this curly thing here?
>> Right, this curly snake like looking thing is
called the cochlea. And the cochlea is filled with fluid. So, when the bones
here vibrate, they actually cause the fluid in the cochlea to vibrate as well.
>> Okay, so we have vibrating air, which goes in to vibrate
the eardrum, which vibrates the bones, which vibrates the fluid in the cochlea?
>> Exactly, and lining the inside of this cochlea are
thousands of tiny little hairs. And when these hairs vibrate,
they cause neurons to fire. The signal gets sent off to part of the
brain called the temporal lobe, which is
where it's interpreted as sound. Something else that's
amazing is that the different frequencies who
actually cause different hairs in the cochlea
to vibrate. Which is part of how we're able to hear so many different sounds.